foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
answering the age-old question Harry
Potter versus Hermione Granger who is
more powerful I'm sure you've thought
about that match up a time or two but
did you ever decide who was the greater
practitioner of Magic on one side you
have the boy who lived the boy who would
eventually kill the greatest dark wizard
of all time and on the other you have
the smartest Witch of her generation and
someone so tenacious that she saved
Harry's life through sheer studying and
willpower time and time again today
we're going to compare the two and see
who really wants the better witch or
wizard between them magical feeds when
we look at magical feeds there's no
shortage of accomplishments shared
between Harry Potter and Hermione
Granger in fact some of their most
impressive Deeds occurred while they
were fighting shoulder to shoulder
taking out Death Eaters on their path to
defeating Lord Voldemort
but we wouldn't be doing our job if we
didn't try to separate Harry's feeds
from Hermione's and see who's were
greater we'll start with Harry and to be
honest it's hard to sum up just how much
the Potter boy achieved his seven years
at Hogwarts were filled with horrible
fights against dark Wizards terrifying
Knights In The Forbidden Forest and over
a dozen battles against deadly beasts
but if we try to narrow our focus and
choose a handful of Harry's most
astounding accomplishments these few are
the ones that simply can't be ignored
one of Harry's most overlooked Powers
was his ability to not only cast a
Patronus but also to make it corporeal
for most book readers and moviegoers the
Patronus Bell might seem like it's
rather weak after all it doesn't cause
any outright physical harm like the
sectum sempra that Severus Snape
developed or the incarcerous spell the
Dolores umbrage used against the
centaurs but the Patronus is actually
one of the most difficult spells to
master and the entire Wizarding World
and Conjuring the spell in the form of a
corporeal Beast was actually the sign of
a master wizard if we think about that
fact alone then Harry Potter is more
than a gifted wizard he's outright
powerful too but to add even more weight
to his achievement what a cast a
corporeal Patronus when he was only 13
years old and used it to repel dozens of
mentors most Wizards couldn't even
conjure a formless Patronus but Harry
did it when he was still just a boy and
that was only the beginning for Harry
when we look at the wider breadth of his
magical feeds there's something that's
hard to overlook Harry's greatest Feats
were in defense against the dark arts
and by that subject's nature Harry
learned most of what he knew through
hands-on experience fighting against
Death Eaters or evil beasts which means
Harry's skills weren't limited to the
classroom Harry was chosen by the
Sorting Hat to wield godric gryffindor's
sword and defeated Salazar Southern's
basilisk with it basilisks were among
the deadliest creatures in the entire
Wizarding World but at age 12 Harry
managed to kill one with the very weapon
that godric Gryffindor used to duel half
of Britain whenever his opponents
weren't able to wield ones Harry was
also a naturally gifted flyer from the
first moment he picked up broomstick
until his very last days in the
Quidditch pitch at Hogwarts Harry was
one of the best Seekers to pass through
the school but most impressive of all
was that Harry became an aura the
ministry of magic at such a young age
immediately after defeating Lord
Voldemort he was awarded a job along
with many other veterans from the Battle
of Hogwarts and by the time Harry
reached 26 years in age he was given a
director's position overseeing the
entire Aura division now when we turn
our attention to Hermione Granger you
might be curious how this witch could
compete but Hermione was no slouch she
was often alongside Harry standing
shoulder to shoulder with the Potter boy
when he accomplished all of these Feats
and her contributions were enormous
unlike Harry Hermione developed her
magical skills by focusing on class work
she often prepared weeks or months in
advance of scheduled lectures and new
spells charms and Potions inside and out
by the time professor a Snape or any
other Hogwarts instructor came around to
teaching a particular magical concoction
or spell Hermione was often already
quite proficient at it and that type of
hard work and dedication paid off for
the young witch Time After Time her
expertise with spells and potions aided
Harry Potter and Ron Weasley in the
group's fights against dark creatures
and wizards when hunting for Lord
Voldemort's horcruxes Hermione
demonstrated her master of Magic by
using Transfiguration to augment her
future husband Ron Weasley's appearance
at Gringotts bank but in that one field
alone Hermione was somewhat of a master
she could change almost any household
object into a magical dragon via the
draconophore spell and in a perhaps more
frightening spell Hermione could easily
change the form of objects into tiny
house mice with the snuffler 4 spell
Transfiguration was one of the hardest
disciplines in the entire Wizarding
World so Hermione's ability to cast such
complex spells was a sure sign of her
status as a master witch just like Harry
Potter Hermione was extremely talented
in the defense against the dark arts she
was even able to conjure the incredibly
difficult corporeal Patronus just like
Harry although hers took on the form of
an otter but one of the biggest
differences between Hermione and her
friends was her ability to concoct
perfect potions when she was just 12
years old she managed to brew a batch of
polyju's potion a liquid that would
transform you into anyone you'd like
when Ron and Harry consumed the flask
their appearance flawlessly morphed into
that of crab and Goyle but this potion
wasn't a cute little magical drink that
first or second years should have been
fooling around with
the consequences for a failed Polyjuice
badge were high and could often result
in death if Hermione was off by just one
ingredient or mixed the knot grass or
the lace swings at the wrong time the
entire group of friends could have
perished and Through the Years Hermione
only got better just like Harry the
number of enemies Hermione faced became
darker and darker and by the time their
final battle against Voldemort took
place Hermione was one of the finest
witches Hogwarts had ever produced and
just like Harry she went on to join the
auras and continue the fight against the
dark arts at the ministry of magic
dueling now when we were diving into
Hermione and Harry's magical feeds it
was hard to avoid the topic of dueling
spells because so much of their magical
knowledge was learned from first-hand
experience from fighting off Death
Eaters and dark beasts and between the
pair of them they might have racked up
more wins against Lord Voldemort
underlings than almost any other men
members of the Order of the Phoenix
let's start with Hermione as a duelist
Hermione was one of the best even though
she was just a student at Hogwarts
Hermione was already deadlier with the
ones then many adult witches when she
was only in her first and second years
Hermione had mastered the levitation
charm before the other members of her
class and that was a sign of things to
come because unlike some of the other
Powerhouse Duelists from her generation
Hermione liked to mix all sorts of
spells together while fighting against
an opponent she could rap a Death Eater
up in a full body bind curse as easily
as she could strike them with the
blasting curse her Mastery of dueling
led her to defeat some of the darkest
Wizards and beasts and a Voldemort's
control she bested the Death Eater
Antonin dolahov hit the werewolf venrir
greybank hard enough to send him flying
and also scored a legit knockdown on
Voldemort's maledictus the snake known
as nagini but even though Hermione was
no slouch it's hard to contend with the
likes of Harry Potter The Boy Who Lived
was forced to raise his wand against
some of the most prominent opponents in
The Wizarding World Severus Snape Draco
Malfoy an army van Ferry and Lord
Voldemort himself just to name a few but
even though Harry faced off against such
terrifying adversaries he was lucky in
one regard he was a naturally gifted
duelist Remus Lupine famously marveled
at Harry's skills and when Dumbledore
mentored Harry even the wise old
Headmaster of Hogwarts must have
wondered how much of Harry's skill was
his own natural gifts and how much was
inherited from Lord Voldemort because
Harry's achievements during his youth at
least were unrivaled Harry's go-to spell
was the disarming charm but that was
just the tip of the iceberg for the
young wizard he was also dangerous with
the stunning charm impediment Jinx and
even used some of Severus Snape's curses
like exactum sempra which would
dangerously slash at opponent's skin and
could cause them to bleed out if they
didn't get immediate medical attention
Harry sometimes dabbled in the dark arts
too he utilized two of the three
unforgivable curses namely the imperious
curse which compelled its victim to do
whatever Harry wanted and the cruciatus
curse which induced immeasurable pain in
its targets and was often used for
torture Harry used all of these skills
to best a who's who of dark Wizards he
soundly defeated Corbin yaxley Draco
Malfoy and even fenra greybach before
eventually achieving what no other
wizard could killing Lord Voldemort if
we just look at the list of Harry's
victories he might have been the most
accomplished duelist of the entire era
conclusion and intangibles as you know
it's always difficult to settle a debate
of who's the more powerful wizard and
this case is no different Hermione
Granger and Harry Potter among the
greatest magic users of their generation
and if either one of them had decided to
join the Death Eaters and serve Lord
Voldemort the entire second Wizarding
War might have ended far worse than it
did but thankfully the lack of ego
allowed the two to become friends and
work together in order to rid the world
of Tom Riddle's evil so if we try to
decide who was greater between the two
who would you choose Harry had the
longer list of dueling opponents and was
more skilled in defense against the dark
arts his strange connection to Lord
Voldemort also bestowed upon him in
particular skills that only a true
Southern Heir would possess and Harry's
greatest intangible the love that his
mother passed to him by her sacrifice
seemed to have empowered Harry
throughout his years we also can't
ignore the fact that Harry got lucky
very often almost as if he and IV of
liquid Luck running through his veins by
comparison Hermione Granger's own
incredible record just doesn't Stack Up
And even though she would undoubtedly
try her best to defeat any opponent good
her dedication to studying in
preparation be enough to contend with
Harry it's a tough call but I think that
despite Harry's accomplishments Hermione
still edges him out on Raw magical
ability but that's just me what do you
guys think let me know in the comments
below and let me know why you made the
decision that you did if you like these
versus videos I've also done Voldemort
vs Grindelwald Snape vs McGonagall and
Sirius vs umbrage until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live